So the fourth of our Beta Sprints to be presented,
John Butler and Wendy Lougee will describe enhanced discovery
through open linked data and crowd sourcing.
I don't know if it's possible for one of the presenters at some
point to give a sentence or two on open linked data...
We're going to move to more of a conceptual model here.
Very targeted in the area of government publications from
content and services point of view.
This is a project a collaborative project that is being
put forth by University of Minnesota, by HathiTrust,
and we have here present its -- members from the trust,
and we have the community -- committee of cooperative --
Mark Sandler, the director of the CIC.
This is a flatter presentation, particularly following the Harvard presentation.
Great job, guys.
So the idea here is to create a critical mass of content
valued and in demand by the community
and build context sensitive
and need of services around it.
And we do this by proposing innovative
and scalable approaches using HathiTrust as a real-life test bed.
As the larger -- largest publisher of information in the world,
-- as the largest publisher of information in the world,
the federal government provides key information resources
that encompass all aspects of US history and culture
and the development of access and discovery
processes that enhance how citizens work with their government.
Because the information resides primarily in the realm of the public domain.
You can see obvious opportunities for exploiting this information.
We anticipate that government information will be a
significant part of the DPLA.
So I'm going to start here with content.
The amassing of large-scale content.
Since 2009, it's a comprehensive of approach to amassing these documents.
Using a framework of digitization,
facilitated by Google and others. The accessing
and archiving of this content by HathiTrust,
and corresponding print management strategies bringing
together four regional depositories.
And just to note that we have the opportunity through the
Google work here to share these digital files.
The status of this is that we're seeking a potential
digitization target of these printed documents of 1.
5 to $2 million and therefore,
we have thus far I think in existence 300,000 in HathiTrust digitized by CIC
and an additional  200,000+ by other Google partners.
We recognize the challenges here of accurate identification of these government publications.
The sourcing of the documents and their corresponding metadata,
and the enhancing of this digital corpus by useful
services, and that's largely what this project is about.
The HathiTrust held its first Constitutional convention
this past weekend or the weekend before ,
and one of the ballots that passed was to initiate a
timing process for a business model
and operational plans for the creation of the complete
government couple of publications.
That's it's really quite well with this proposal.
Moving on to these services,
contextualized services around government publications.
We've been working with a community of government
publications libraries to identify what would be the most valued services?
One is to deal with the problem of US government,
department and agency name changes,
as you encounter that confusion
and chaos in searching and navigation
and the second really is to provide some sense making in
terms of legislative histories. That is,
how do we link these documents together in some kind of genealogical fashion?
So we propose to use concepts of linked data.
To deal with both.
But primarily with the name agency changes.
Is example you see some of the variants of the US Coast
Guard including the life-saving service preceding name,
and the reverse cover service and on work.
-- cutter. When a user searches for Coast Guard,
our were they aware of these changes over time?
Troubling not. We are seeking to use linked data
and RDF triples to move away from that concept didn't
insert -- in terms of soul research and retrieval
and leveraging the relationships between one data store
of bibliographic data and existing external
or internal data stores were name authority changes can be better managed.
And so there are a growing number of data aware stores out there.
Including the library of comment -- Library of Congress,
the virtual international Authority file, and so forth,
these are just waiting to be tapped in order to create
on-the-fly relationships between documents
and information service -- objects that reside in one
place and that of another.
And here's a little bit of flow how we might imagine this working with the HathiTrust.
Moving from a catalogue heading,
using an RDF triple that relates one entity object in HathiTrust
or information point  to that where it exists in another
data store and returning a related name,
a related piece of information based on the request.
It could be presented back to the user on-the-fly.
It could also be used to enhance records
or enhance queries that the user would be conducting within the search engine.
And here's an example of how that might actually play out
in the user interface. Searching for US Coast Guard,
a touch to these other data or services,
they deal with the variants names preceding
and following names. And either by explicit
or implicit inclusion of these alternate names,
could be embedded in the search without the user having
awareness of those three nations.
The other objects of our project is to make sense out of legislative histories here,
and this is probably the least ugliest slide that I could find.
We hear a lot about sausage making with legislative
histories, and it really is the case here.
This is a daunting challenge here as we look at the find. relationships again,
the key to this project is building relationships between information objects, documents and such.
How do we do that with legislative histories?
Here's the simplified version of that. Hard to read here, but again,
we see this as a combination of algorithm that proper --
approaches, clustering documents, public Law numbers,
and interventions by the professional government
publications community as well as possibly end-users
understood and editorial controls.
And those are the interventions thereby tagging
or perhaps even the intervention of these -- the creation
of these RDF triple users.
And the keyword search that would help us a stack these
documents up in some kind of related history.
So just to wrap up here again,
we're talking about the continued a massive of government
obligations content on which we can create, build, interesting and useful services.
And finally, again, this is the front slide here.
Our proposal was submitted as a short video,
the URL is there. I don't know if it's Obama blog site,
John. I know we put it up on the wiki site as well.
That's another resource for that. Thank you.
Excellent, John, thank you.
[Applause]
I have a hunch that my friend -- my friend Carl would like to say something.
I will send the mic in his direction.
I have a question.
You say you're authorized to share those government documents with the government,
with the government printing office.
One is, do you feel at all interested in getting access?
And can you share those documents with other groups such
as public resource or in the archives
or commercial operations or whatever?
To this point,
there is no interest from the government office.
That's been expressed. To that second question,
Google's willingness to share with other partners, --
Really the discussion we had with Google was specific to
GPO. And you know, I guess always go back
and talk about that.
I think it would just be -- what's the nature of the
vision that someone wants -- for which someone wants to
use these documents? I wouldn't foreclose it.
Our specific escutcheon with them was that.
Okay. Other comments on this?
Yes, Sir?
As the mic goes along,
I would say the GPO would be a wonderful part or in this as well.
I'm not sure if someone is here from GPO,
but we welcome participation..
I'm a retired vice president of a digital company,
and my response ability was in government documents but I
want to comment a little bit on the difficulties that
Mark and his colleagues have alluded to.
If you consider that congressional committees are either
standing committees or standing committees,
the standing committees are fairly long-term,
and they're seldom more than 100 of them.
They're not internal, even though -- not eternal.
But the special committees are completely different thing.
Either select committees -- special committees,
there have been over 6000 of them in American history so far.
And the names of these special or select committees
often do not appear on the reports
or documents themselves.
They'll have some kind of a name,
but it will be a crucial role,
like a committee of that part of the president's message
of the third instinct.
Now comes the real name is locatable in the House
or Senate Journal for that session,
but it doesn't appear in the document itself.
It's not something that ever could be extracted by full
search. Requires research I through cataloging
or some other form of intense research to get it straight.
So all of this is by way of saying perhaps,
it can be a very, very complicated process.
Thank you. Acknowledged. Awesome.
I think we're going to move on, but any response to this?
I think we recognize the complexity of these problems, and in fact,
that's what's inspiring us to try to do -- chip away at
it with some scalable methodologies here.
But fully acknowledge these are very complex information
structures, if they exist at all.
Fantastic, team, thank you so much.